[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu vois les caisses qui fait on va pas
les qualités des travaux qu'est ce que
c'est qu'un conducteur de travaux
c'est qu'effectivement des lignes des
pylônes électriques
comment s'appelle exactement votre
métier conducteur de travaux
d'équipements électriques quoi se font
remonter les pylônes pour pouvoir passer
courant après ou non cliquable
il emmène le coin je suis presque 10 à
quoi ça sert tout ça ça fait mal et le
courant est ce que tu pourrais expliquer
comment comment commence pas ce métier
exactement le métier de ligne arcand ça
s'appelle ligne a ont fait pour monter
les pylônes et promettre génie ou cool
dit simon dans ces trous et montrent le
pilote ou par vous alors à fracturer
ligne comme on l'aimé autant les câbles
de poulies on les passionnés poulies
autant tous des câbles quand on
construit les lignes haute tension
puisque c'est votre spécialité qu'est ce
que vous avez à faire sur tout ce qu'on
a à faire c'est l'exécution en totalité
de la ligne
[Musique]